okay hi how are you I missed my cat no
oh he he needs a haircut today is Monday
in the World of Tanks video just went up
on Saturday if you haven't yet seen it
go check out the World of Tanks video
what's the call it is like I bought my
son a tank but finding an affordable
tank for my son
there's probably end card for it as well
you can go check out that video if you
want I'm so distracted this morning and
we didn't kill anything last week for
the tank video that we put out because
we were super busy trying to get it
finished so the tank video there's some
defects in there they were pretty cool
and I kind of wanted to talk about some
of them and we didn't get a chance to do
that last week so that's what we're
doing now what up Gabe hey speaking of
people who helped on B effects
it's the beep hey mr. P yeah cuz someone
stole my my whiteboard how did this go
it went well we're talking about it now
you're pretty late over I was here all
day Friday it was like an 11-hour day
Dan I was not on set when everyone shot
this video so I didn't really understand
the scope of what the video was gonna be
and the tanks are very ridiculous in
nature they've got missile pods and
missiles and guns and turrets and all
kinds of weaponry attached to these
tanks just making them absurd and that's
kind of the joke for instance here's the
opening shot Sam basically just took a
few still frames for each of the tanks
and just sort of with the pin tool just
drew a bunch of missiles and random
stuff on there just kind of give a
visual layout of where this stuff will
be in the scene so this is the first
shot this is the second shot so here he
was like oh yeah we're gonna want to put
like some missiles up here it's a big
missile pods on the side and you just
want to like make this ridiculous
looking expensive tank the problem is
that it's not easy to find 3d models of
a tank with a super long barrel and all
these missile pods and those don't exist
as just natural assets that people want
to buy like I think Sam spent $100 on
that 3d model of a tank in the final
shot of the video I've managed to get by
just fine without ever learning how to
model typically for video if we need a
3d model we will
usually look on online marketplaces for
them first and we had a smile budget so
I purchased a few different models of
various to tank things weapons missile
turrets so here's one model that I
downloaded I don't even know what this
is it's some sort of like gay mask that
I think but it has like these cool
missile pods it has a sweet looking like
little ball head military thing this
isn't this doesn't look like it'll go on
a tank how am I supposed to work with
that what we did for this video was we
did something called kit bashing kit
bashing and that's the idea of taking
various elements from various things and
frankensteining them together into
something that is more than you started
with and so that's exactly what I did
first off I split that ball head thing I
made it a lot larger same thing with the
the radio dish I separated each of like
those missile pot arms and I actually
took the leg of the base of the the
tripod turret thingy I duplicated that
and I turned it into basically arms that
attach to the missile pods because Sam
wanted a specific place to put those
missile pods but then I how would they
attach to the tank if you wanted a mount
you scared me
dude that's what these are see what this
is right here son see this that says
razor on it apparently Christmas don't
come early this year I mean is there
another way we can approach this other
than just like
[Applause]
yeah I got a really high precise clicks
and clicking on the premiere timelines
as you guys know and the better the
mouse the faster I click and the faster
I click the faster I added at a video
and the fast right of the video
the sooner comes out in the corridor
channel so that's the goal with these
boxes here I think the CPM is up I'm not
talking about YouTube ads guys how much
how much blade do you think I need to
open these boxes this much blade whoa
whoa oh that's way too much too late
it's not California legal this much
blade looks like a bunch of lipo
batteries wax wrap death adders are they
Wireless of any of the hardware makers
that we've been working with razor has
been one of our longest lasting partners
they have supported us all the way
through they have sent us a care package
since we are upgrading all our pcs
they've given us the best mice and
keyboards and more to make sure we get
everything out of these computers I'm
wired guy I like wired mice I hate
replacing my batteries more than
replacing batteries is finding out oh
you need to replace the battery link now
yeah click is begging I don't understand
why dogs are not more popular for
wireless mice just like oh you're done
for the day just put in the doc you
never have to worry about them that's a
really good idea there are mice that
have that and the place is just not more
prevalent try me dude I don't know it
changes colors I am particularly excited
for what's in this box I think I know
what it is Wow we'll never have to buy
keyboards again yeah I'm excited for the
keyboard dude I want that I want that
BlackWidow chroma dear Razer thank you
for the birthday present
be nice to our Hardware no we're getting
comedic any shots of everything getting
replaced that's what you call Vaughn's
and cutting it's funny to beat up helps
keyboard it's re being replaced by more
handsome keyboard like what gonna be
like funnier it's funny it's just like
it's it's whatever is that ready Oh
another thing I did for this shot is I
made this giant plane this giant wall
here and I put just a 2d texture of
trees on it so you actually get like
proper like reflections of the forest
surrounding the tank area so here you
can see this is a tank little thing here
in the middle it's obviously a little
yanked out so these missile pods are
cool select the mega rocket it started
off as just one of these things with
four missiles on it and I can isolate
just this piece what I see when I look
at you know a missile pod such as this I
don't see a single piece of armor
holding four different missiles I see a
whole bunch of different components that
I can duplicate and move around at will
so you can see the center piece right
here is actually just the thing holding
the missiles duplicated and turned
around and so that'll actually sit
behind the tank itself I was like man I
want to put something here in the center
and that was where that that turret came
from the middle piece of that turret
with the little eyeball head on top of
it I thought that would be great
but then the little head was way too
small so I detached that from the rest
of the 3d model and I just quadrupled it
in size so now we have this really huge
like missile tracking the camera ball I
think what do you call it a drone a
drone ai-jen a so yeah this is what's
called kit bashing you take parts of 3d
models from various different places no
there's an artist called Vitaly bulgar
ah've makes some incredible 3d models of
robots and all kinds of really really
cool stuff and in fact he has a store
where he actually has a bunch of kit
bashing 3d model parts it's virtual
Legos you can just take all these
different pieces and assemble something
from the ground up like that's what kit
bashing is on a smaller scale I did that
by breaking apart existing 3d models as
opposed to buying a kit bashing set
now don't get another real Niko and you
have certified that saber saboteur
subburaj yes we're gonna open some
campaign with Alex's gift some birthday
it's a birthday present from Alex how
old are you 32 so this is a knife
specifically made for opening champagne
bottles the champagne saber so at first
hold on to fly should we read the
instructions of the warning I think it
just said what does it say what is this
a saber should only be used by an
experienced Somali trained in the art of
subburaj so brah keep away from children
we could take all the foil off yeah and
then you take the cage off too but keep
your thumb over it this is how they did
it in Lawrence of Arabia to you
specifically want the Cu the scene there
yep
leave the camp shoots off shoots off
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but not
now oh and I he's not here turn the
other way it's gonna go great it could
it go hard Alec couple are gonna go 30
20 Clanton's I think it's gonna go as
far as that white turn hi
the cage is coming off boys all right
dude cage all right so how do you do
this
you just hold it down first morning like
it okay come on
you gotta put some real good muscle into
that oh you put some fidelity I'll try
this
okay the scenes already anyway you've
you know you're ruling it wrong hold it
yeah yeah yeah actually cut it actually
cut it I'm sorry I'm here guys pointed
it to anyone right now
looks like do that a little bit maybe
that's why the only change to Rogers's
possibly well sweet nice
I mean got a drink a little bit campaign
like this erosion of leash baby let me
[Music]
[Applause]
nice clean cut I got one two three four
plus twos guys real name